en octubre de 2019 cientos de chilenos
se lanzaron a las calles sin saber que
un año después tendrían la oportunidad
de decidir sobre una nueva constitución
rechazaban el alza a los precios del
pasaje del metro de santiago y aunque la
medida fue retirada las protestas
continuaron y se extendieron a nivel
nacional algunas de manera pacífica y
otras derivaron en saqueos y daños en el
transporte público
modelos implacable rápidamente la
protesta se convirtió en un movimiento
que se prolongó durante meses inconforme
ante las desigualdades sociales del país
genera cambios profundos profundos desde
la educación la salud las pensiones
todos
el despliegue de la fuerza para contener
el estallido social puso al presidente
sebastián piñera en la lupa de la
comunidad internacional señalando lo de
ser el responsable de violaciones de
derechos humanos el 30 de noviembre de
2019 amnistía internacional había
contabilizado más de 300 lesiones
oculares por balas de goma y al 6 de
diciembre la oficina de derechos humanos
de la onu documentaba 28 mil detenciones
entre las cuales había denuncias de
torturas y violencia sexual
la crisis obligó al gobierno a dar paso
a la creación de una nueva carta magna y
reemplazar a través de un referéndum la
heredada de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet
la consulta estaba programada para el 26
de abril pero el brote de kobe 19 no
sólo provocó su aplazamiento sino que
también ahogó en gran medida las
protestas la palabra plebiscito tiene
gran peso en chile en 1988 el pueblo
votó para sacar a pinochet y devolver al
país a la democracia ahora los chilenos
buscan aprovechar esta oportunidad para
cimentar la igualdad y borrar una oscura
mancha del que hasta hace unos meses era
uno de los países más estables de
américa latina'